the jurogan experience when i was
working on the iron man project is uh
the iron man project
it was the iron man project
so we're trying to build to suit
really we've been working on it for a
long time i didn't know i was on the
beginning of project it was called
carnivore at first and a few other names
but in the beginning there was only a
small handful of us working what are
they using to make the body suit out of
it's it's changed so much right now that
it's
all kind of materials i mean titanium
carbon fiber all the top stuff and is it
supposed to be able to fly
it's going to do a lot of stuff does it
have an exoskeleton oh it's stronger
yeah and it's much stronger you can
carry you know a thousand pounds yeah a
lot you know i've seen that stuff that
stuff's wild we're getting there but if
you think about that kind of a suit that
exoskeleton
how are you gonna move that exoskeleton
those people so if you had if you had a
squad let's just say you had 12 dudes
and those exoskeletons what airplane are
you going to use
what homv is what vehicles how are you
going to get these guys around what
boats
it changes everything right there's a
thousand pounds yeah
so you can only get like a couple of
those on a plane
yeah maybe four i don't know but that's
but that's one of the issues that we're
running into is the fact that if we
start going in this direction we start
going extra skeletons we have to change
everything else that makes sense and
when we were doing it it was like the
long pole in the tent for the you know
and i was on these think tanks and i was
always like the innovators see i was a
weird seal you already know that i guess
well i guess
that one gets to that part i was a
techie fart so i was very technical and
i was working a lot of the uh national
laboratories so all the places that we
built the you know manhattan project we
still have all those facilities all
around and so we still use them we work
with them and we try to push the
envelope for military and civilian use
so there's a lot of things that i was
part you know innovator inventor of
stuff that's gone to the civilian world
and uh
the iron man project was really cool and
what are they powering it with that's
the problem was that i'm pulling a tent
i kept talking to him and i was working
with all the national labs pacific
northwest and all those guys
and uh
nuclear battery was pretty much the only
way you can go
so it would be that it'd be a little
battery about that big bro
we've already got the cell phone in my
pocket but we've had those little
nuclear batteries since the 50s so it's
not a big deal but those nuclear
batteries like how dangerous it for a
human being to be around it
how dangerous is to being a military
that's true too we jump out of airplanes
30 000 feet but if you i don't feel like
if you wore that thing around you got
horrible bone cancer because of it yeah
you get
lead shielding a bunch of other
shielding yeah but the thing is there's
so much power and there's so much
everything else we're using the uh
hypersonic flywheels and using all this
other stuff we're trying to do energy
storage in all kinds of different ways
is there a way
to shield it so that a person can be in
direct contact and not receive you
carried around in a suitcase really yeah
yeah jesus christ
yeah there's a couple of them isn't it
funny like that's the one of the things
that we're scared of the most i have to
be careful with some of the stuff i say
i'm like are you constantly going are
you saying stuff that you're not you
could not edit it out you're saying no
there's classes iron man is not
classified anymore they've talked about
i think it's in popular mechanics now
so but i think some of the people that
worked on it are still classified and
some of the stuff they're doing now is
probably classified so this is all that
all data is that a situation where
as new technology comes out then they
revise it yeah until they so they're
always working on it but it's not always
working on it so it's it's it's usable
some of the pieces like right now i mean
my back is just toast like all the seal
team guys because we carry those large
rucksacks and constantly out there jump
you know free falling jumping parachute
and all that stuff our backs were just
toast
so what they're trying to do is trying
to get it just first is like load
carrying and so they made it try and
that was one of my biggest pushes in the
beginning of iron man was i said we need
to build everything
as
non-energy consumption everything has to
be uh you know pneumatic or springs or
somehow using our body to propel
everything because if this whole thing
shuts down the battery turns off you
have to still be able to move a little
bit at least to be able to get over from
here to cover over there so you don't
get you still have to be able to move it
so it's a thousand pounds how do you
move that thing right there's no power
how would you is that possible
like where the direction they went in
was the direction i didn't want to go
was you can't now you can't it's you're
gonna be stuck so the power goes off
you're frozen you're just yeah you're
almost
it's big imagine if you were in the
middle of some sort of an operation and
there was a solar flare yeah and the
solar flare nukes all the electricity
yeah
i mean how the [ __ ] could you move it
how could you if you're stuck in a
thousand-pound robot
you're done that's what it looks like
right now yeah so these things are still
tethered a lot of those
okay so that is um yes the exoskeleton
goes down his legs and that's those
things on his legs yeah but that's
that's even a way newer that's
cgi i don't know if that's a real one
and so but it's pretty much like that
and it attaches here around your waist
and it kind of works off of your hips
and then uh so this is one right here
and so you see he's got this
down the sides so that's that's a that's
a regular one with no power so that's an
unpowered one and what's going on inside
these little things on his legs and up
around his waist it might be slightly
powered but those things on his legs and
they'll have up there will be like a
piston really and then that will as
you're moving your leg
it all works off your own kinetics you
know it's all off and it helps you move
yeah and it can carry large weights so
you can go faster and carry a lot more
weight why don't i have one of those in
my life i need to find one of those
paralyzed people they run up hills they
work with paralyzed people they have
people that are paralyzed and they can
attach all this stuff to them and they
can walk around and do it so this one is
powered and see where he's got a thing
on his heels like that yeah that was a
big thing because when you step your
feet pivot somewhat so you have to watch
these things where you put it and how it
goes up there's so much to this thing
you would not believe it it's wild
there's a lot of technology in that
right there alone and so ultimately they
want it where it covers your body like
an iron man whatever
that's the ultimate would be when you
start putting armor and everything on it
so you can see that
and so that's all lightweight stuff
robocop [ __ ] yeah that's wild that's the
direction we're going in but you can see
even that guy right there he's gonna
have a hard time getting out of vehicles
and doing a lot of stuff so as you keep
adding this stuff on there we get bigger
and bigger look how big that guy is
he'd have a real tough time getting
inside of any vehicles yeah and he
definitely is not driving anywhere so
that's so that's what the pros and cons
it's like yeah we have all this we have
that but now we have to redo the
vehicles we got to do this there's a lot
too how in oh that might be if you look
up carnivore and how are the first one
how far do you think they are from
developing
autonomous robots that replace people
anyway in these situations
i think so with weapons because the
stuff i was working on
10 and 15 20 years ago
and how fast we're advancing back then
so i would i would walk into a place and
it'd be a via chip manufacturer for us
to do our sneaky peaky bugs and stuff
and i would show him and say hey this is
what we're working with right now and
then we would give them three million
bucks make it half that size and it's
all weird you have to say here's three
million half the size
and then within six months i'd give it
to us here half the size and so when
we're doing it and for my budget i think
i had like 60 million dollars so and
it's we it's huge budgets when you get
to top levels of the seals
and we really push it and we're
constantly pushing these envelopes of
technology and so you can kind of see
like even when i was there i know the
sizes and i know that you can have a
chip and you have a chip inside of a
chip and a chip and a chip and a chip so
you have you can go all these layers all
the stuff you start digging
and then every time you have the
chip there's a lot of subroutine and sub
programs and everything else you can put
into them there's it's just mind blowing
how advanced we are so if you when you
say do we have autonomous right now we
have airplanes vehicles we have all of
it already
we're fully careful right now to go
almost autonomous